you are Laura and you're on your way to
a very important job interview in the
morning across state you get in your car
late and start heading towards the
destination unfortunately your car
breaks down and no cabs are around the
pick you up you must hit your eyes with
complete strangers to make it to your
destination be careful though never know
what's out there
hello everybody my name is Mark Lauren
welcome to rides with strangers now the
full game isn't out yet um this is just
a demo so thank you to Wade and the
developers for getting the access to
this so this is a new experience for me
even though you guys may have seen this
before but this is new for me so don't
spoil anything in the comments below
while I'm playing be respectful
okay so when a car is coming you must
stand by the road to be sure the driver
can see you once a driver continue zoom
into place at I icon on the car once the
eye icon turns fully wet it will Andrew
hitch mode there you must press space
key once he icon turns green okay great
you must survive the ride enormity your
destination
why is that the only option why can't I
have a friendly ride with a friendly
stranger the happy stranger that gives
me candy and tells me cool stories about
the war oh boy rolling down the window
will give you some fresh air Oh a wild
ride mode keep an eye on the changer do
this by simply pressing a key to look
left left will prevent them from
attacking you every time you look at the
trainer will fill the sketch meter up it
was the sketch meters for you no longer
look at the stranger some balance is
what answering the questions correctly
will Druce the rate of the string to
attacking you ah rolling down the window
will give you some fresh air and help
you calm down at any time you can tuck
and roll the pit hill down to the car to
re-enter hitch mode and keep your
distance progress oh if you tug enroll
more than twice you'll be sent back to
the first spawn if you roll the window
down hit sir times are cutting
ah great press enter did enter suicide
No thank you I'm okay I'm gonna play
this other normal mode because I still
don't know - hi how you doing buddy how
you doing friend oh boy look at this
have you seen her that's not a good sign
for the first thing that I look at stand
under the arrow okay I am gonna do two
philately do this oh good there's
already a car on the way something tells
me there's only one possible option for
this and that's the tuck and roll as
soon as possible
oh man I have no I have no idea if there
are actually different strangers in this
but considering it's only the demo I
imagine in the full game there are gonna
be different
oh I was supposed to I was supposed to
do something wasn't I
ah well that was probably the only
kind-hearted soul in this game and
anyone else is gonna be a murdering
psychopath gray oh I'm uncomfortable
already but aren't we all
isn't that the great experience of life
to be as perpetually uncomfortable as
you possibly could be oh okay
you're do I dare one ah there we go much
success did that say much success it was
that mission success I'm not under sin
sure hi hello friendly person other
friendly human good evening child how
you doing out there
oh you know take a seat and let me give
you a ride no I'll walk all right fine
we'll play the game please send thanks
for warming it up with for for with for
me I'm comfortable what about you
so it's at the egg he - look at him so I
don't get murdered
ugly I mean what a handsome devil look
at you literally a devil this is a
dangerous place to be hitchhiking huh
what is a precious young thing such as
yourself doing out there are you know to
take care of myself
dangerous why's that I ate your piss -
[ __ ] creep I'm a lost sheep going
through the burden of life yeah I'm a
lost sheep the Lord has brought you to
me for a reason then and we shall
discover it it's busted
okay what was that does it your foot
locked that's always good
oh man that meter goes up quick huh a
meter compared to the travel meter which
imagines is a sour close we get to the
destination oh that goes up quick huh
well we have quite a ways ahead of us
oh yeah eh I asked where is it you are
traveling oh you know seven things
important meeting then I shall get you
there before you are miss would I be
missed huh oh [ __ ] how often am I
supposed to look at this guy don't go
what are you doing there scratching your
nose or reaching for a gun
I can tell by the way you are dressed
and present yourself you have ones that
love you
I was forsaken at Birth by my mother was
raised by fathers why do I care about
this um oh did I they probably would be
happy I got picked up by you friend
yeah to think someone else could have
found you before uh-huh can I can i tuck
and roll already
can i tuck and roll like I can't reach
over there why can't I tuck and roll oh
geez oh geez oh geez oh geez
well there we go oh okay okay so I got a
press D to look over to the right Shh
how are ya
so funny we have this each this each I
can't control I try to run away from it
oh just brings me to you I'm not gonna
scratch your scores of the scorpion oh
the river doesn't the scorpion kill the
Frog at the end and I think I know that
one it's a beautiful parable about how
it is difficult to act against
oh okay oh I'm a tuck and roll soon I
have made a vow with God to purge the
heretics this exchange he suppresses so
it's come time to ask are you a
god-fearing woman oh I praise the man
Jesus blasphemy dare what did I do
I didn't do anything I chose you I pray
real hard every day all day oh boy oh
boy
what did whoa whoa what is that what is
why is this what is the worst thing I've
ever done uh get in the car with a total
stranger see what uh six grams of coke
up my ass and [ __ ] your mother what
about about you oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you must
chin roll down the window holder canned
oh god bleep oh God not tortured many
organ boys are my passion but I pray to
God to forgive and Glenn are you choking
rule that's in bed oh I can't come there
forever
ah the [ __ ] was that
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] Garrett [ __ ] off dude what
the [ __ ] was that I was looking at it
all got him in the car again action it's
a fragile nightmare who'd have thunk
maybe I should have bailed out I pretty
sure I should have bailed out when I
started hearing the moans of his last
victim in the Christ getting the maximum
okay I'm talking to roll tuck tuck roll
let's get out of here tuck roll
well [ __ ] I think it's said that I could
keep my progress which is nice
barely maybe oh oh god damn it how was I
supposed to be able to make it all the
way down
oh hello what is that is that there
another car on the way wait I'm in the
same place I was maybe I did say my
friend it's cool if I did say my pockets
everybody over to ebony ebony ebony
ebony please please this better not be
the same guy there's better enough be
the same guy is it the same guy it's the
same guy hi hi same guy all right are
you doing out there oh I just broke all
of my ribs trying to run away from this
crazy priests oh [ __ ] okay oh come on
man no I don't reset god damn it
oh boy getting close getting close to
maximum creepage hey hatred it will [ __ ]
hey I shouldn't look at him when he's
doing that I don't think there's any
reason to do it I just want to make sure
that he doesn't stab me in the throat
I'd be nice okay
maximum creep achieved maximum creep
take it all baby
take it all
learn one day to not let me chuckle you
think it's an old car with no electronic
locks oh no oh I thought it was you
couldn't talk more than two oh [ __ ] well
I'm definitely [ __ ] aren't I well I
sure AM okay so somehow I gotta get
through this on just this is a dangerous
place to be hitchhiking I gotta get to
50 percent of precious young things such
as yourself doing out there I have to
get to do a boy see I have to get to 50
percent presume you can that's not gonna
be good I'm not gonna make it to 50
percent
oh boy I'm not not gonna make it he's
gonna kill me he's gonna stab me he's
gonna murder me he's gonna die me he's
gonna kill me yeah Eric how are you
supposed to make that I guess don't ask
him what's the worst thing he's ever
done for one god damn it okay so the
game crashed unfortunately which is bad
because I was just about to beat it but
I did when I restarted I was reading the
instructions again and I saw something
that I did not see before and that's
that I can click on the speed limit
signs to make him go faster you
distracted the driver go faster please
oh [ __ ] I get a deal window thing I
don't think he can I don't think he'll
kill you when he's talking or when
there's a question being asked
I don't think that happens okay I'm
pretty sure everyone else could have
found you before shirt or
yeah I'm a hundred percent sure now that
he doesn't kill you when you're asking a
quickie is asking the question or you're
being asked to glacial parable or he's
talking or you're answering I don't
think I don't think it happens so
that might be a way to get through the
whole thing in one go okay I'm
definitely farther than where I was and
I'm definitely doing better whoa hey
whoa [ __ ] yes [ __ ]
a little better anyway Hey
hi I even smiley wookie everything can
determine the outcome of their lives as
in the scripture of James 1:3 you know
that the testing of your faith produces
perseverance I leave that everything
happens for a reason
um just chaos ah my face is unbreakable
and you are truly blessed
you're Eric house Oh who's gonna do it
oh so close on one try son of a biscuit
eating bumper nugger son of ab ample
flamp
I must have missed some like road signs
or something oh hey hi hi hi friend
hi okay that's weird that's really weird
well that's weird
Oh again with the double oh okay double
looks alright cool I know I'm very
attractive and all that but you need to
stop that it's not that very much almost
there ask a question please
yeah come on
oh [ __ ] that
why didn't he ask a god me I'll [ __ ]
that and I'm it's not gonna work cuz I
gotta restart it cuz it's just gonna do
the double fine just kill me again
fine [ __ ] know what do you do what do
you do what are you doing how god set
this you see I have this eat yeah keep
talking buddies if I can't keep talking
I tried to run away from you just keep
talking story
the scorpion
yeah oh here's we're nearing the end of
our journey together child yeah wish we
had more time
oh hey I did it
Oh didn't I I didn't get murdered I
didn't get stabbed in the neck Oh
joyous day man that was difficult to do
I don't know how you could do that in
one go um it seemed to me that the only
time really to look at him was when he
was looking at you because that seemed
to be the Tessy and he would do to two
different things he would look at you
straight on for a long time and then he
would also do this lingering like just
side glance and if he's that count says
him looking at you so if he if you
glance over and he's doing the little
side II you got a look at him until he
turns away or looks at you so you got
those are the two things to watch out
for the other times he's not gonna kill
you so you only got to watch out for
those who you got it like somehow spend
only your time on those things instead
of lingering on him when he's not
looking because that's a waste okay but
anyway that is rides with strangers um I
don't know if there's a way to publicly
access the demo but you can still
support the game it's still in
development so check out the link in the
description below and thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
right Rhaego